what we really need to do as a society
is invest in a series of activities and
and areas that we've been neglecting the
average American is working longer hours
today than he or she has you know at any
time since you know many many for many
many decades what this means is that as
we have sort of over-invested in money
and consumer goods and so forth we've
let other sources of wealth erode we've
neglected our communities or families
and our planet so austerity is is really
not addressing that issue we've got to
actually take our effort our money and
our effort to investing in the things
which we have eroded because hollowing
out our communities hollowing out our
families long our life's lifestyles and
so forth undermine well-being and they
undermine our ability to actually have a
more plentiful and abundant future one
of the ways to think about it is that
from the ecological point of view it's
pretty clear we need a major shift to a
whole new set of technologies the
technologies of the Industrial
Revolution which took nature as if it
were endless and in free supply and we
could pollute the atmosphere without
ever paying attention to it pollute our
rivers cut down all our trees and so
forth our technology our economic system
the way we value things it's all based
on that idea which is a crazy idea and
and the sort of the chickens are coming
home to roost on that as we've d fouled
the climate run down our ecosystems and
so forth to get to a new kind of
production and consumption system which
actually respects and restores the earth
it means we're going to have to do a lot
of investing but that's investing at a
local scale at a smaller scale it's a
whole different economic model than the
one we've been
sing